hello rejects Greg Alva here and this is
okay hi I'm hope James after Obama ran
for president how much like oh wow no
Trump Hillary no that didn't really
bother me it was like two minutes
oh really hope and it's not like it was
bad
well that conversation didn't not go
where I was hoping it would go yeah
anyway the walking dead right-hand man
season 7 trailer a lot of people have
been telling you to watch this since the
release of my CC and I found out what
Hope showed up that she actually hasn't
seen this trailer and that she watches
the walking guys and we want to do a
video after this about who we think
negan will kill and why he will kill
them or at least who we want negan
akil's it's like we have to choose who
we think we think will die and who we
might want to die yeah
so let's watch this trailer first and
see what they have to offer
okay now with sneak peek at the season
premiere of The Walking Dead
Ricca stole my what was a joke that bad
I'm gonna kill you
so Rick is alive
not today
I'd like the same facial hair
Simon
what do you have nice
yeah hatchet hatchet in max
Simon's my right-hand man as one of
those important I mean what do you have
left without work you have one maybe one
of these fine people still breathing
well that's method yeah
give me his ex yeah who had an ax mix
towards someone who got killed had an ax
not
I remember anyone with an axe
Hey
did he say his axe if not well we can
just turn these people inside the ones
that are left
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
okay all right so it's confirmed that
Rick is at least still alive not gonna
lie at one side I wanted him to die
because I was like really well you know
like in Game of Thrones they like kill
your favorite people yeah yeah that's
sure and sometimes you're just like
what's gonna happen now I mean I didn't
want rape to die but I just wanted to
see what would happen
um who-who had an axe I wonder if he
killed more than one person like that
would be cool actually if he killed more
like is he he does say like the ones who
are left and he might be just saying
like okay I killed one and the other
ones are life if he killed you know two
people that would be more of a surprise
I feel like people would you know that's
true because it's like like you got to
be able to have like one person's death
be impactful enough and you're not just
distract from another person's death
yeah I really love what's going on with
negan
I think Nina's gonna be such a cool part
of the show I feel like the governor was
the last truly he was a great villain
for the series yeah they haven't really
had someone who's been able to top the
governor I really feel like me and half
this way more sadistic way more cruel
because the governor didn't view himself
as a bad guy and I feel like negan is
pretty much aware that he's a bad fella
you know yeah and I feel like he
embraces him not being a good person as
part of this world and part of what
gives him power so I feel like this is
really gonna be a clash of like a Rick
being good and he can be an evil I feel
like it's gonna be a good clash wrap the
season I also really like just classic
scared of the walkers yeah I feel like I
might I ever really focus on that it's a
long time I really it's just annoying
like you have this whole world of Walker
and then you're like come on negan just
get out of my way we have bigger
problems but that's just what I have to
deal with right now
yeah I don't know how excited I am about
Meegan so you don't really love the
human drama as much I don't I really
only because I just I just don't like
drama and like all the relationship
drama I'm just like you know if he just
stayed in his corner and ate his own
food you mean you don't like like Rick
and Michonne like [ __ ] each other do
you like it
I think interracial sex is a beautiful
thing I love it I just don't like the
way they introduced it like one moment
they were just best friends and I loved
that they were best friends and then
suddenly they were sleeping together I'm
like I did not get that feeling at all
and yeah it felt force I didn't uh
didn't feel like there was anything
really leading to that yeah it was
someone like there's like hey like what
a shock I want to be like okay yeah
let's do it yeah go at least get a sex
scene of them like I know that can't
show nudity but they're all they're both
attractive so I agree yeah I was both
attractive they don't like the rough
kind of killers in the group we should
see like some like there's a show I love
called Jessica Jones and Jessica Jones
and Luke Cage have sex and they're both
super strong beans and some when they
have sex special kind of sexy and I feel
like this should have like that special
special sex scene the showing like the
roughness behind them unless it's just
like cute love me do you see them to
keep the love relationship I think after
this I don't think they're gonna go back
to it I think whoever died is gonna
affect Rick so much that he probably
can't get it up and I think the whole
reoccurring theme of the show is how
Rick can't get it up and how he has to
tell he's looking he's breaking in a
grocery stores looking for viagra so he
can try and make love - Michonne just
once more there's not and I did like
that line when he said is a year see
Watchmen and the guy plays in the again
played a character called the comedian
oh and I felt like when he said was the
joke that bad at the opening of this
clip yeah something kind of felt like
even though I know it's referencing
the earlier thing that he said in his
speech I felt like it was somewhat pain
tribute to the fact that he played the
comedian which was like a very standout
character in the movie
oh yeah that's a trickle down to hopes
my what if he has no hands that's true
yeah what is negan gonna do - Rick I'm
not a fan of talking about certain
subjects somehow it's game brought up in
my second video with hope
what but come on there's something that
people are probably going to think negan
might be doing a Rick oh you don't see
it that would be very traumatizing
didn't happen a Rick like that would
make I think I may need in like the
ultimate villain if he was willing to go
that far with like [ __ ] someone up
that bad alright I'm on board like I
don't see it as like vegans get up the
bill instead of just beating up Rick or
something really sort of like let's take
it to level where he's like super
traumatizes him you know huh oh I wonder
if people could handle that but I mean
we're the seventh season in they gotta
push their boundaries man they gotta
push to live yeah how many seasons is
this this is video 7 season oh I don't
know oh we're gonna see how far they can
you know direction said yeah would you
survive
apocalypse is that you're a real
question yes would I survive a zombie
Apollo
I feel like movies and show some told me
everything I need to do to survive I've
been thinking about that I think the
only way to survive is if I like keep
hidden by myself
yeah yeah although I am pretty tough I
just I also can see a world where I'd
die quickly yeah it's a zombie it
depends on the kind of summaries we're
dealing we do they run fast oh good yeah
they run out hump - I'm gonna be so
scared if I'm not a great shot I hear I
can like I've tried shooting stuff
before and I'm not really good at
shooting oh I'm good at missing I'm
gonna accidentally hitting the target me
too that's like my specialty luck memory
of who we think negan killed right now
but before we do that I do want to say I
don't think it's gone
I'm just gonna put that out there I just
don't think it's fun I know in the
comics it's Glenn I just don't think
it's him why for some reason when you
said that even though it wasn't an
argument really it made me go well maybe
actually this other reason tune into
that I don't know what it is no all
right guys subscribe to this channel
keep a lookout for the these speculation
video we're gonna do hope James you can
go to her I will wipe sue it I'm doing
it hope James you got her webseries
uncool calm that it or uncool the series
I'm calling the series calm yeah that's
just like a short comedy series can you
pitch it um it's not like to
20-somethings learning how to deal was
not being cool and trying to make that
cool is it based on your life yep I
think you're kind of cool I know but
it's because I'm so not cool I come out
the other end cool yeah but then once
you think they're not cool tend to be
the coolest ones exactly that's why this
is uncool like me like if you're not
cool but you're so cool because you know
you're not cool
you just embrace how not cool you are
you are cool it makes me so cool is how
uncool I no I'm not yeah
go there and follow her on Twitter as
well she tweets occasionally yeah
sometimes I feel pressure to be funny
part of pitching yourself as a funny
first okay all right